hello there looks like we're gonna
trailer here for the 12 year old
supervillain Artemis Fowl it's movies
just to come out in 2019
[Music]
[Applause]
ever imagine
very important thing I have to do da
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector you aren't
supposed to see this yet
[Music]
your father is in a complicated
profession for years he is protected
powerful secrets that have kept mankind
safe from the dangers of another world
okay it's time to face your destiny it's
a real Percy Jackson vibes personally
been implanted multi-talented giant
dwarf and I'm Hollie short your honor I
on the other side okay I can tell why
this movie got delayed
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that looks like Aquaman
[Applause]
[Music]
mastermind
Optimus didn't breathe much our truce
anything wants to do back before that he
was a supervillain he's like a master
thief or something right
oh boy that that looks like a lot of
stuff that looks awful yeah I mean that
was the thing I kept thinking throughout
this trailer was sort of this looks like
a tough sell if it has the exact right
tone it could be fun and whimsical but
if it doesn't it's gonna be kind of
painful I mean I think Catherine
directed this right you bring a lot of
fun fantasy adventure I think the action
looks pretty cool it looks pretty sweet
this looks like a cliche super cliche
hero's journey movie a lot of
questionable effects throughout this
this is gonna flop I'm just telling you
right now it is gonna flop like I don't
know how like loyal the fan bases to
this cuz this is a pretty big book
series right yeah I remember like when
we would who were those calm we were
kids and then they would bring festivals
like school yeah yeah Artemis Fowl or no
spell was like always there yeah for
sure
I haven't read Artemis Fowl but I've
heard about him over the years it
there's nothing of what I've picked up
on so I can't sit here and be like oh
you will not so my Artemis Fowl however
I will say I highly doubt this is the
case because right now this gave me
nothing unique at all and the idea of
life you know a 12 year old supervillain
who grows over time and is on a
Redemption path that sounds like a cool
movie and then this looks like typical
like a hero's journey hero's journey
space opera sci-fi action adventure
mishmash hodgepodge I got some of the
Wonder they were going for but
everything looks so candy-coated and so
polished and also it just kept reminding
me of so many other movies you spat it
out men in black and then I was thinking
of like Harry Potter and I was thinking
of Valyrian and Percy Jackson and a lot
of other things I don't know there's
something about this that yeah it
doesn't feel like it quite has its own
soul on the inside it just has its
unique character set up you know oh he's
the son of the
greatest thief or whatever yeah this
seems like something that has been held
up in production for a long time and has
probably been kind of polished down into
something that looks very shiny but yeah
I didn't connect with this
well the teaser trailer came out I
pulled it up here 2018 of November I
think the supposed to come out in 2019
production delays sometimes movie it's a
heavy production delay in the movie ends
of fine I'm saying it looks bad yeah I
don't mind saying it will be bad yeah
I'm saying it probably yeah cuz I like
the actors I mean the lead dupe who's
playing Artemis looks cool looks like a
charming young lad this didn't give him
many moments to let me get to know them
yeah we kind of had that one look on his
face the dad trope is a Disney thing I'm
seeing a lot now yeah man times let's do
it Chris pond Josh GAD looks like he's
doing something different which is
exciting
he looks letting my makeup and do a
voice it looks like he's having a really
fun time with that the closest thing I
can liken this to is that max steel
trailer like some of the action looks
cool but this just looks like they
didn't really read into what made the
franchise in and of itself a very unique
specimen and they don't seem to be
honing in on that instead they seem
likely to read tweaked a lot to satisfy
as many as they can is my Bob Iger step
down yeah it's like I ruined my Artemis
Fowl through you guys I'm out of here
but I do have a suspicion and this often
happens with us Kenneth Branagh directed
films I'm thinking Murder on the Orient
Express and Thor specifically films that
are like these big studio movies and
then when they market them they hone in
on stuff that's more of like the heavy
serious stuff but when you watch those
movies there ends up being a lot of
humor and I think that's what's actually
missing in this trailer and I think
that's why everything kind of comes
across like really cheesy very campy and
corny unintentional too but when you
like look at the villain here like I got
your father it looks like out of a
low-budget BBC show or something right
and I'm thinking that if the movie has a
sense of humor about itself that all
could work right now this comes across
like corny they're playing like this
badass rap music over it and it's just
not meshing I honestly do think that the
trailer is not good I'm thinking though
knowing kenneth branagh films this could
be something that's actually better than
what the trailer is currently presenting
to us well yeah because the thing is
this is a PG movie and this feels like a
trailer that wants to convince you of a
pg-13 movie and I think that's partly
clashing with his tone and perhaps
selling it short because yeah this needs
to look like something that is
fantastical enough to engage adults but
that you know has the spirit for the
kids out there who AR being introduced
to the book now and who can bond with
their parents over those books and yeah
for what little I do know about them I
guess the main thing that concerns
because that is a good point it seems
like they've really changed the
character dynamics around to the point
where this reminded me of just kind of
the generic plotline we have now if
you're really special for because of
your lineage and now you're gonna
discover your secret Batcave and you're
gonna go on in a world spawning
adventure you know couldn't really tell
what makes this entirely unique from
this change yeah we got the page pulled
up here on the Disney Channel which I'm
sure they're gonna appreciate us doing
this let's cover the top comments and
see what they got in store man I'm
apparently we should make a movie about
the Artemis Fowl series you read the
books first
nah you know I can see that meaning
that's fair enough
that better not be Artemis we see
fencing the Artemis we knew nearly died
climbing a ladder and that fencing
sequence looks like it's shot to look
awesome that's the case yeah you know
what the vibes I'm getting from this are
they're more like stuff like Alex Rider
like said max steel Last Airbender
yeah annotations that's kind of an
impression I'm more getting Artemis was
the villain in the first book all the
other books are Redemption straight from
his evil yeah that's pretty that's what
I've heard for fronds sake he would
kidnap Holly but no he has to be the
hero because it can't be that we do
Holly with a colleague
she character right Disney I was Holly
the girl yeah oh god yeah I read that I
was like what is going to upset people
oh yeah from again from the little
things I know when she popped up in the
trailer and was like come on I was like
wait a minute are you at odds with this
guy for the time of watching this this
video has 240 6969 views and it has
three points to XK less than one point
six gate dislike that theory stands
correct I think this will flow just like
how this person saying I think this will
do well the box office we'll see when
released Disney Plus would have been a
better this looks like a Disney Plus
movie I'll take book adaptations were
they for story elements from later books
into the first movie ruining their
chances of sequel for 400 alright guys
well Artemis Fowl what do you think are
we judging too harshly often I read the
books but I'm already watching this
going like this does not look that good
so I'm gonna I'm gonna apologize for it
I think it looks great
please thank you John subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell check us out on patreon
do a lot of stuff over there if you live
in California presidential primary
elections make sure to vote do your
civic duty